hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be looking at game 13 from the match of
the century which is the series of the
1972 World Chess Championship between
buddy Spassky the current champion in
Bobby Fischer the Challenger but he's
fast keep playing the white pieces he
two games ago in the white pieces in a
game eleven ended up winning against the
Sicilian defense Bobby Fischer tried to
come back in game 12 with the Queens
gambit declined line was unsuccessful in
taking an advantage turning it into a
victory so Betty Spassky has a little
bit of some momentum even though he has
two points back in the overall standings
maybe get started same thing he did in
game number 11 which is pawn to e4 Bobby
Fischer instead of playing this Sicilian
defense which he lost against maybe
psychology but today I'm gonna change
things up and play the Alekhine defense
with Knight to f6 but he Spassky pawn to
e5 Knight to d5 and decided to go and
play the the modern variation the
mainline pawn to d4 had the option of
playing the to pawn attack with pawn to
c4 forcing the night away but decides
instead play the mainline pawn to d4
pawn d6 and the night up here to f3 most
common response from Bobby Fischer would
have it is to play Bishop down here to
g4 decide to play something pretty novel
at the time pawn to g6 here raid the
Finca to his Bishop here to g7 Bishop c4
Knights back to b6 attacking the bishop
bishop back here b3 now the bishop comes
to g7 fianchetto on the King side Knight
to d2 which is somewhat in strength
could have easily seen just Knight to c3
makes a lot of syncs castle on the King
set if you wanted to could have even put
more pressure on as opponent with Knight
to g5 already had his Bishop on b3
eyeing down the square on f7 but decided
to go and play Knight to d2 more than
likely looking to either bring it to c4
or a4 so that he can get the dark
squared Bishop it involved into the game
castle on the Kings side for Bobby
Fischer h3 pawn a 5 starting to attack
on the Queen side and as expected
generally what we're seeing a high level
play is when once I started to attack to
this 5th rank for black
fourth-ranked for white to the other
side just kind of counters that with
their own pawn so pawn to a4 from buddy
Spassky pawn takes on e5 we do see an
exchange in the center of the board and
then Knight to a6 and this is kind of
interesting because you might expect to
see Knight to c6 attacking this pawn
right here can come down to this outpost
here on b4 but this is threatening for
this night to come to c5 attacking both
the pawn here on a4 and the bishop and
gets a little tricky if the knight comes
to c5 and then the bishop comes back to
a - it's the rook is no longer defending
the square here on a4
why decides to go ahead and castle on
the King side if we look at it there's
no great way to really stop him from
doing this so he does just that
he doesn't worry about it right away
castles on the King side
Knight to c5 and then Queen to e2 this
is kind of what we're talking about if
Bishop to a - his pawn could just fall
honey rat a4 because his rook can no
longer defend that so after Knight to c5
we see the Queen come up here to e2
Queen over here eh this is another
attacker so that we have both Knights
and the Queen from Bobby Fischer
attacking the square here on a for now
the knight comes to e4 s we talked about
does need to control the center the
board and allow this dark squared Bishop
here on c1 to get involved into the game
that's gonna take here on a4 go up that
pawn of material because there's no way
for white to really stop this the bishop
takes and the night's gonna recapture
does have protection from this Queen
here on e 8 Spassky continues with rook
to e1 just centralizing his rook a
little bit my back here to b6 wants to
make sure that he can get his Queen
involved to not have to worry about
protecting it also wants to be able to
push forward with his pawn
and lastly wants to make sure he can get
his Knight over to the center of the
board and protect that as well Bishop
here to d2 attacking the pond but then
there's palm pushing forward here to a4
starting his attack on the Queen side of
the board Bishop to g5 trying to cramp
the position of black a little bit
decides to go ahead and just play pawn
to h6 for seeing the bishop
come back here and then Bishop to f5
attacking the knight I thought he might
actually come to Bishop to e6 that makes
a lot of sense but then when he saw his
opponent play pawn to f4 brought his
Bishop back and you kind of look at it
you start to see some air in front of
this King right here from white so I
think all in all he gets the position he
wants and just gets his opponent to play
as pawns maybe pushing a little bit
further than he would like Knights a d4
attacking the bishop bishop down here to
see for attacking the Queen Queen comes
over here to a d2 so if we look at both
sides of the board black is doing a good
job up in material he has the the pawn
advantage he has both of his bishops
which white does not have a paired
bishop on board and so all in all this
is pretty good also if you look from
White's perspective he doesn't have the
safest King side of the board so why
it's gonna have to do something if he
wants to have a advantage getting into
the endgame because Bobby Fischer one of
the strongest players getting into the
in game Queen here it's a d7 work over
here d1 wants to make sure it's
controlling this open file in the center
of the board rook to e8 pawn pushing
forward to f4 and this kind of signals
kind of what we expected to see is
White's no longer trying to be defensive
on the King side it's an all-out attack
for white so he's gonna be pretty
aggressive the rest of the game Bishop
to b4 or d5 from Bobby Fischer Knight c5
attacking the Queen Queen comes back
here to see it if you can't look at it
Queen to d8 it's just a little bit worse
he would like to play pawn to e6 just
solidify his pawn chain a little bit
make sure he's not as cramped but the
bishop here on h4 would then be
attacking the Queen so once to make sure
when he retreats he retreats back to a
little better square and that is Queen
here to a c8 Queen to c3 upon here to e6
trying to alleviate some of the pressure
on board King to h2 and that up here to
d7 and then Knights down to d3 this is
one of those interesting moves anytime
your opponent is kind of in a cramped
position you usually don't want to
retreat your position I could easily see
just taking here on on d7
then if the Queen recaptures I think
that's fine for white but just coming
back here to d3 all of a sudden I can be
pretty aggressive on the Queen side the
board with pawn to c5 and so I think
buddy Spassky did give up a little bit
of momentum that he had going and Bobby
Fischer took advantage right away
Spassky plays Knight to a b5 Queen
appear c6 Knight to d6 it's an outpost
but it's not real an outpost because the
Queen can take and after the pawn takes
then the Bishop we can come down here
take on a c3 they exchange material
right here but now all of a sudden White
has these double pawns on the C file he
also has this pawn up here that's kind
of by itself for now and it's gonna take
a while for him to get some material to
actually hold down this so all in all
great exchange for Bobby Fischer and
that pawn to f6 does not want the bishop
to come up here to e7 this would be a
great outpost or really controlling a
lot of critical squares deep in blacks
territory so that's kind of what he's
trying to block with this pawn on f6 and
the night here on d7 is doing a good job
of protecting that pawn pun up here to
g5 trying to blow this up and that's
exactly what happens and then pawn to f5
and so all in all pretty good exchange
for Bobby Fischer Bishop back here to g3
King f7 Knight to e5 attacking the King
Knight takes on e5 Bishop takes on e5
and then pawn over here to b5 starting
to push over with his pawns on the Queen
side of the board rook to f1 and then
the surprising move with rook to h8 not
really sure exactly what he was looking
to do just give up his rook here because
I think it makes complete sense for
white to take here on h8 didn't have to
do this could have just played let's say
rook to d8 I think that's completely
fine attacking this material right here
in the center of the board but decided
to go ahead and play rook over here to a
h8 and as surprising as that is because
Bobby Fischer has a huge advantage right
now
white decides not to go ahead and take
that instead plays Bishop here to f6
which is an out
host allows him to start to push this
pawn up the board if he wants to but
he's given this material on h8 I think
he should go ahead and take this pawn to
a3 rook up here to f4 pawn pushing
forward on a to its is a passed pawn and
Bobby Fischer's pushing it quite rapidly
and it's just a gonna be a thorn in the
side for buddy Spassky the rest of the
game or at least until he can take this
material he pushes forward with pawn to
c4 this does open up the door for his
dark square bishop to control the square
here on a1 the bishop takes the pawn
pushes forward here to d7 but you can
start to see that White's giving up a
lot of material and all of a sudden
Bobby Fischer is up two pawns of
material he has a huge advantage on this
board now Bishop to a d5
at this particular time the game was
adjourned if you're not too familiar
with how some of these World
Championships were set up back in the
day you would play a certain amount of
time and then both players would
actually adjourn for the day they would
go they would rest up they would talk to
their teams a lot of these teams will
have three or four top level players
that are analyzing every move looking at
different situations and then they would
come back the next day and they would
actually finish that game out that
they've spoken to their team's about
they've looked at it themselves and so
this was it was kind of an odd time
knowing that so many people had looked
at these positions but Bobby Fischer had
a winning position as far as material
advantage but no one could really find a
winning combination that he could get
the victory here but Bobby Fischer being
kind of the interesting lab that he was
stayed up until 8 a.m. the next morning
now the games start at 2:30 p.m. in the
afternoon and he was just looking at the
position he essentially said that
there's no clear victory even though he
has a clear advantage
there's no moves that he can just play
and then if a white plays optimally that
he'll win but he said he needed to mix
things up and try things to do a little
bit differently than he would from an
optimal standpoint and see if he can his
opponent to make some mistakes and that
would be the only way that he could
actually get a victory and when they
came back buddy Spassky played a king to
g3 rooked
here a three check upon c3 blocking the
check work over here to a8 this is okay
I'm not gonna give you that rook anymore
rook to h4 pawn down here to e5 and then
work up here to h7 if you can't look at
and say why didn't he just take this
material right here it's not going to go
well Bishop takes here on e5 and then
Queen on a1 just promoting after the
exchange right here this is gonna be bad
so he knows that he being white
but he's basking in this position that
upon 2a v e5 this stops the bishop from
holding down the fort on a1 so he needs
to continue to be aggressive and that's
why we see the rook up here to h7 check
wants to make sure that he continues to
not allow this pawn coming down here to
a1 so King to e6 rook over here East 7
check and then after the King moves now
the rook can come down here to e5 and
now there could be a discovered attack
and he would be able to defend at the
square here on a1 again work over here
to a c3 King f2 so getting out of check
look down here see to check King comes
back here to e1 and now decides to go
ahead and gobble up that material on d7
rook here to d5 doubling up his rooks
and attacking the King right here keep
me over here to a c6 rook to a d6 check
kind of maneuvers the King around the
board and then all of a sudden there is
an exchange you kind of look at this you
know we've gone through thirteen moves
Bobby Fischer's given up a rook he's
given up a bishop and he's kind of left
with his opponent with a bishop he
doesn't have a bishop on board himself
but he has a pawn advantage in this
particular spot he has three pawn
advantage which immaterial is equal but
it's all in one side the board which he
has all of his major material with the
king and the rook and nothing's in its
way and so he kind of looked at this and
said this is my best opportunity to win
to just push these pawns and see if my
opponent can make a mistake Fischer
continues pawn to b4
up here h4 king b5 pawn h5 pawn c4 work
over here a1 stopping the threat pawn
takes on h5 pun appeared to g6 and then
a very very good move from Bobby Fischer
and it spawned to h4 says you can't
really take with your Bishop right here
because then things just start to fall
apart rook over here to g8 threatening
that pawn if the rook takes on a 2
that's fine because this particularly is
going to be a very easy in game for
white if he no longer has a threat of a
pawn then black can easily push these
and get a victory so a nice little move
knowing that his opponent can't really
take this pawn right here instead
decides to go and start pushing with his
pawned pawn here to g7 pawn down here h3
Bishop up here East 7 recover here to g8
and there's kind of two options could
play Bishop to f8 and you may look at
and say well that doesn't make a lot of
sense if you want to protect the pawn
let's go ahead and play Bishop here to
f6
this also defends the square here on a1
the problem with this particular move is
let's say pawn pushes to h2 which is
exactly what Bobby Fischer's are gonna
do make it really difficult for white to
defend both sides of the board and so
the rook is just gonna have to stay back
there we're over here to h1
he's already defending the square here
on a1 so we got that covered but then
pawn to c3 King here to d3 rook to c8
and this is kind of that decisive move
where he can now use his rook to start
to push and he has a defense so it
doesn't even have to use his own King or
pawn and so but he's fast he can look to
this and that said yeah I don't want
this rook to get involved I'm gonna put
my bishop on maybe not the best square
as far as controlling the rest of the
board especially that a1 square but I am
going to lock out my opponent from
playing his rook so he plays Bishop here
it's f8 all of a sudden Bobby Fischer he
only has pawns now that he can really
play with this is locking down both the
bishop and upon protecting each other
the route can't do anything there's no
real pieces that Bobby Fischer's going
to be playing with the rest of the game
pawn to h2 as we
expected king over here to see - King up
here to see six this is one of those
where definitely seems like a bad move
could have played pawn to b3 King beef
to pawn to f4 starting to put pressure
on the King side of the board
we're over here to h1 f3 I think this is
gonna be very difficult for white to
hold on to this plays that King here to
c6 but white I think place about William
plays rook over here to d1 giving that
right back
now pawn to b3 King c3 and then Queen
down here to h1 this is another mistake
I think from Bobby Fischer and I I do
understand he's trying to mix things up
but some of these spots I think he
played sub-optimally pawn to f4
continues the pressure he doesn't give
up a pawn that he doesn't have to
because after pawn to h1 he doesn't
really get anything back from that I
mean he plays King to to d5 but he could
have done that himself after he played
pawn to f4 and he still would've had a
threat here on h2 now this rook doesn't
have to worry nearly as much as he did
before but King - Abby - and then f4
work over here d1 at check King to e4
work over here c1 King B 3 and then rook
to d1 this is probably the one of the
biggest mistakes in the end game for him
buddy Spassky he really needed to play
this rook to c3 to give himself a chance
maybe King to d4 and then recover to f3
just threaten this pawn on the Kings
side of the board his king over here
although it's on b2 it's protecting all
of these pawns they can't really do as
much as they would like to as soon as he
pushes one he can just gobble up some of
the others if he wants to he can also
get his bishop involved into the game if
he needs to to really protect but as
soon as he plays rook to d1 King to e2
is a dagger very difficult for white to
hold on to rook to c1 trying to threaten
but now pushing that F pawn even more F
to e3 rook takes on g7 says yeah I don't
want to have to worry about that anymore
now I can get my rook and
often to the game finally a rook up here
to see for a rook to d7 rook to e4 King
down here to f1 Bishop to a d4 and then
the pawn comes down here to f2 and in
this particular spot the game is over
now what's interesting is in this
position they shook hands some of the
crowd actually thought that this was a
drawn game they thought that rook to f4
would stop this
but after looked at for the rook could
take if the rook were to take then King
up here to e2 there's no way to really
stop the advance of the pawn coming to
f1 for a new queen so at the end of the
day buddy Spassky was forced to resign
they shook hands Bobby Fischer ended up
leaving very quickly and buddy Spassky
just kind of looked at the board with
his team trying to figure out how on
earth that this what they considered a
guaranteed drawl ended up in favor of
Bobby Fischer winning from all the games
that we've talked about so far game 13
has gotten so much attention from the
entire chest community over the years
because of Bobby Fischer's play and
finding a win out of something that
everyone thought was draw former world
champion Botvinnik
actually said this game really stood out
to him because he thought was the
greatest achievement from Bobby Fischer
he had a draw opposite colored bishop in
game by sacrificing his bishop and
trapping his own abrooke and then he
gave five passed pawns the opportunity
and ended up with the victory he said
something he's never really seen in
chess before other players were saying
that this was Fischer's finest moments I
think he had some moments you know
earlier in his career that were
spectacular but the fact that he was
playing the black pieces he the past two
games probably hadn't played his best
losing two games ago and last game
giving up an advantage and not being
able to capitalize coming into this
where you know he's trying something
different with the defense of Knight to
f6 Alekhine's defense getting into
a end of the day one where both teams
kind of looked at and said I just can't
find a victor here and Bobby Fischer
came out on day two to finish out the
game with the victory a very very
fascinating game just to kind of go back
and watch and see how he orchestrated
that so great game by him that is game
13 hopefully everyone is enjoying the
series specifically a game 13 but thanks
for watching the video and I will see
you guys next time in a game 14